what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
the pre-game
before i start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
the way you're you're going to be
notified of my daily videos as you guys
know if you have watched two or more of
my videos and you do not subscribe we
have beef okay
beef
what's up
okay guys so um as you guys know you
need to turn on your notifications for
the live we go live every wednesday
thursday and saturday night at 9 30
roughly you know sometimes we'd be late
um but turn on your notifications and
make sure you like the video it really
helps us with our engagement and it
helps us with the algorithm on top of
that all super chats are going to be
read so if you guys want the panel to
read something or you have a comment
that you want read make sure that you
super chat it and lastly um our sponsor
today is cooking with chris so cooking
with chris is a completely customizable
meal plan so basically you give the guy
foods you already like eating okay it's
not it's not like keto it's not like
meat only like all the weird diets that
people do it's fuji already eat but they
customize it to you to make sure you're
getting the nutrients that you need guys
i lost 20 pounds on this meal plan like
that i really recommend it the link is
in the description okay so
we have some special guests on the panel
tonight um why does everyone go around
say your name your age your relationship
status
and
um where you're from
and where people can find you
right um dt when you say where you're
from country or
where you're based area in the uk um you
could say say where you live now where i
live now okay lovely my name is dt i'm
33 and i'm from
london
um taken not single off the market
and yeah you can find me in star
official dtm one
you done yeah i'm done bro
yeah it's me
melinda the fourth um i'm coming from in
my opinion podcast lovely to be here i'm
from london uk
um i'm 32
and i am currently off the market
i thought
[Laughter]
yeah that's me
okay i'm sasha i'm 25 i'm from new
mexico and i am single
okay sasha single and free
hi i'm stephen chuck d um i live in east
london i'm illegals boy
i'm single
no discount
[Laughter]
it's your boy uzi
one of the one of the one-third of the
in my opinion podcast yes from ken
um
[Music]
relationship i'm gonna be i'm in a
situation
i swear that's
[Music]
yeah my name is mr tetz i'm from london
30 years old and i'm currently in a
relationship
that's it so i guess it's just me no i
was free
okay so don't say i was three cuz you're
a bit confused
what no he's a bit confused that says us
for you we're single but i'm like he's a
bit confused so oh okay so it's like
yeah conflicted conflict why are you
confused exactly i think it's a good
question yeah what's what's what's the
problem
everybody wants to know is she not spicy
enough
i'm still confused
about your feelings
my heart is still somewhere else oh my
god oh
situation
i see that sucks to be you
hmm
okay so
um our topic tonight is the amber heard
and johnny depp case so
have any of you heard
amber heard testify
yeah
very wild
if i was a lawyer i would be
wide to just dismiss myself on the case
um so basically for the people at home
that don't know i'm sure everyone
already has seen this case but basically
a couple years ago
johnny depp and amber heard were in love
they're day in they're having a great
old time they get married right
um until
after it ends amber heard comes out and
says that she was abused
and this was during kind of the me too
era of hollywood like every everyone was
coming out and saying they were like
abused or whatever like left and right
and for the most part companies were
just taking the woman's side
so in this case johnny depp um
was dropped from pirates of the
caribbean and basically from any major
like place that wanted to do movies with
him he was like dropped all the sponsor
is gone um well she didn't name him by
name um she she did a very public
article
saying that johnny abused her
so
now
it's a couple years later
johnny has decided to sue her for 50
million dollars
saying that he was the one being abused
so
yeah defamation
so
um the question that i have
is should women go to prison
for
robbing a man from his livelihood
um
who wants to say that stop over there
bring it around
we'll finish it
yeah i think so since you guys are the
ones in the hot seat
i have no words right now
play the fifth
um i can start if you want yeah go ahead
um
not to change your question or anything
i think anybody that wrongly accuses
anyone of anything that impacts their
livelihood should definitely go to
prison
and i think in this case
i've been on the i've been uh on a jury
before you know not in america but here
in london so i can think like a juror
watching
johnny depp give his uh testimony and
then watching amber heard he's more
believable yep she's very much coming
across like a fantasist like a really
bad actress personally um i feel like
even her lawyer
man objected his own question
you know and i just feel like a lot of
the stuff she's accusing him of like i
saw a video where she accused him of at
one time they were in the car together
and apparently had the dog out of the
window and everyone in the car was shot
but then we've seen a video of her doing
the exact same thing
you know with the dog in the car outside
the window so it just seems to me that
everything she's accusing him of
is pretty much the stuff that she's been
doing to him we heard the voice note oh
you're a man you go and tell people that
you're you know you're getting abused
and see if they'll believe you and
that's what happens a lot of the time so
personally i just feel like
i don't really believe what she's saying
um and i kind of side with johnny depp
on this one
so follow-up question
do you so let's say
let's say he she was abusing him right
yeah and he hit her back
and she wrote the article detailing
things that she he did do but she just
missed the part where it was in
self-defense it just missed
very convenient very convenient yeah
right right do you think in that case
is it still a false accusation
it's not a false accusation but it's
like a half truth you know what i mean
but then again
if he hit her in retaliation then he's
still in the wrong
that one i have to you know
break that down i think so
yeah break it down break it down
i've got to break it down because
i don't know about i don't want to speak
for the uh speak for yourself
i've been in a situation where
i've been slapped i've been punched by a
woman you know she might have gone
through my phone and found something
wild you know you know it'd be sometimes
pearl on these streets
you know oh you know do tell i mean it
happened it happened you know
adolescence yeah you know what i mean
you know
i've been cheated on i did not slap him
you didn't slap him no was he taller
than you smaller than you bigger than
you he was bigger but like that's why
yeah was she bigger than you i mean she
she we could have gone round around
like i mean i'm pretty tall i mean you
are you are i just feel like you're
either a girl that hits guys or you're
not dumb
yeah yeah that's true by the way
you're all right without having to go to
five yeah yeah like i mean where do you
stand on the violence
i see where you did that yeah so what if
i used to be i used to think like you
did right so i'd be like no he shouldn't
mention or hit women but it forget let's
say i just punch you right now right
let's just say what's in there right
uh-huh
you have i just think like you have
every right seriously yeah like if i
laid hands on you and i know that you
are stronger than me i know the
consequences and a lot of girls
well let me say a lot of people not let
me not just say girls but like some
people will take advantage of it like
let's say a woman knows that
he won't hit her back and she'll
continuously do it so i think amber
is like the type of person to do
something like that i agree with you so
like explaining that like she didn't
explain that he was doing it in
self-defense anyway
so that shows just her character and
what she's willing to do or what she did
do so let me kind i say something
i mean in the society we
we live in right
we it's clear that
there's a double standard
right
i believe that for
whether
but in this case we're talking about a
woman right
i strongly believe and advocates for
a woman going to prison going to jail
if you forcefully accuse the man because
in the society we live in this man has
been ripped off his livelihood
everything everything and his labor and
the thing is
when a man is accused of like domestic
violence or like rape for example
it's a stigma that never lingers
even if he's found not guilty he never
leaves correct and
acting is this man i've been you know
i've been
watching johnny depp movies since i was
young yeah yeah i was young this is this
man's livelihood
and
even if he's found not guilty there's a
stigma that still remains and from time
women have got gotten away with things
like this it's fact women know that
i can do something to you and play the
victim i need to go it's to go my way
women know that's true you know women
know so a woman knows that if
if i hit you
and you hit me back i can play the
victim and you go you you know you get
into trouble
right so
i personally i don't advocate for men
putting their hands on women but
if i had hands put on me i'm putting my
hands back on you
unfortunately
i don't i don't agree
i'll put my hands back on you if if
if you know if
man if you put your hands on put my
hands back on you man it is what it like
the [ __ ] is equal right equal
baby
i like it because you want it you can
pick and choose you can pick and choose
when it comes to equality you have to
take everything the good and the bad you
can pick and choose i wouldn't put my
hand on a woman you can call me every
name in the book that's fine
but when you cross that line
if i decide not to hit you back
it's me doing your doing you a favor you
don't tell me well if you hit me i
decide okay not to retaliate it's me
deciding that not
it's not cause
you know
i just think like if a skinny dude walks
up to a bigger dude
and hits him he's like he's good will
and chris yeah
that was a good example yeah but i don't
like more like more like okay if chris
hit will okay first yeah
then like will hit him back and he got
knocked out yeah like nobody would
question nobody cares yeah yeah but but
if a weaker woman hits a man
and gets knocked out but i think he's
like that sympathy sort of
you know people automatically get
because
everybody roots for the underdog
and i think in that scenario all the
time nine out of ten women will always
be the underdog
and i feel like that's why
you have the imbalance
where
even if she hits you
the world expects you as a man
because of how strong you are the
strength you have
to be able to restrain yourself
and that's where i think you have the
disparity and
that's even kind of like playground
that's exactly why i stand there i've
been hit before i've never been hit by i
have i've been i've had something thrown
at me like close range what was it it
was a bag you died yeah what you ducked
it no no he slapped me in the face
it's all right you know what i'm saying
if that was a bomb yeah it was a bottle
was different i would have got knocked
out this way
by the time i woke up
but i don't i don't think i think
because of the disparity as you said
between like male and female strength i
don't think we should be hitting women
like regardless of if she has slapped
you whatever she does to you your own is
to try and um
restraint de-escalate yeah escalate the
situation restrain her what if she
brings a knife oh yeah then defend
herself try and take the knife off her
obviously you're not gonna know i don't
know
how did that turn out for that guy in
miami
the guy the guy got stabbed
and he died it's his girlfriend yeah oh
i swear that would be you did he try to
defend himself or did he get a knife
but that's a completely different
situation he's not here to explain
himself we we we can't we can't liken
the two one one is fist and one is life
that's two different things what would
you do
if your
person came to you with a knife i'm
cutting bro i'm running i'll be honest
with you
what you i'm gonna i'm gonna stand there
and fight someone has a knife i mean
male or female bro
i mean oh god
i think like you're in a room right you
guys are a room you can't get out yeah
she has a knife on you i have to punch
her up bro
no but again a knife is different from
just fists you understand there's life
and death and there's just embarrassment
but yeah because really that's just
embarrassment i also think as much as we
want to tell men to
[Music]
to um you know keep their hands away
from women which i strongly advocate for
i also think women also should be told
to stop hitting men
it shouldn't be your first or second
result
it should women should be focused
because
you can't
you can't see somebody stronger than you
and you want to
hit that person and you're expecting
that person not to retire can i say
something to you yeah let me flip this
on you yeah i think to myself the reason
why i'm with tets on this right
and don't get me wrong though i'm what i
would personally i would not even if she
hits me i would never hear a woman i
don't care fair enough but
what you guys are saying i also do not
disagree right
i'm just me you know i'm just like that
so the reason why i'm saying that is
that bro i look at it from this point of
view
if she knows
one punch from this guy is putting me to
sleep
maybe even brain damage right
and she's hitting you regardless with
all her strength
she clearly needs help
this person isn't okay and i'm happy to
say my point because clearly she's not
doing proper calculations ahead that bro
this person is stronger than me if i hit
him
if he punches me back he's a rap
that's not our mind of the same person
and that's the reason why i personally
would just walk away from that situation
like if i'm in a relationship
and you hit me
like relationship that's you basically
saying you know me and you've had this
conversation bear time that's you
basically signing off our relationship
is just his way we can't we can never
come back from that once again
that's what i'm saying that's where and
that's where
i treat that because bro you're a man in
the sense of that bro the same way
you're we're talking about you men are
stronger they're more superior and all
of that stuff same way you can you can
dust
so i would take off my black it's
happened to me but i've been punching
the chest before wow funny enough
physically i took off my shoes dust them
together like an african man and i put
them on and i walked out the door
so just footless
yes sir but when i got outside the door
i put it straight back on
his way
so it's just just
it was for me for sure to let her know
that yo this is what's going on
do you know what i mean in it so i just
feel like because let me show you what
it is you're right
you need to be smart as a man right true
so the point when i say that is this
right
look at johnny's situation
you are never going to win in that
situation
off the rip
true
maybe in the long run like two years
later
you might try to do something like this
right
but it's too late damage is done he's
lost how much how many deals how much
millions but guess what how much what
the stigma so so the point i'm making is
that right unfortunately in life right
i'm at the point like i understand that
there are certain scenarios in certain
situation where
women have the upper hand
and there are other situations where men
are the upper hand is the life that we
live in and unfortunately the society
that we live in the being putting hands
on a woman that's just one of the things
that they've got upper hand on do you
think that women would act better if
they were afraid to be hit
i think if they change the laws
i think if they change the laws around
how men are treated when when police
arrive on the first response and the
woman goes i'm the victim
right they don't care if the man is
bleeding and half dead
if she got one if she has one little
automatically he's going to jail for
that night we will hear your story
another time another time yeah so i
think if they change the laws around
that and women start to see that yo
it's no longer that way i think it might
change things but as long as that the
law is on the women's side the way it is
right now they're never going to do that
yeah it is too much of a risk
and i think i'm thinking more of that
from that perspective you're very you're
very right in everything you said
but the type of person i'm willing to
take that risk
i'll tell you let me tell you
something let me tell you something
there's a risk i mean
so um
obviously if a woman hits me i'm not you
know immediately going to hit you back
yeah it has to be repeated yeah i would
warn you hey stop it i'll try to
restrain it but there's a way you might
probably maybe
you you're slapping me at first i'm
trying to restrain you then you you take
exactly as a strong woman yeah i i'm an
asleep too so
you punch me or something
how would you know absolutely i don't
mind like when the police come it's fine
i mean i'm in cell i'm in jail yeah
happy you know i'm laying down in my
cell and i'm like say happy birthday
it's okay
it's okay but
i feel like i've done other many people
i don't like i said i don't disagree
with you man's point of view of this but
if you're brave enough to hit a man
you need to understand the consequences
with that i don't
disagree i'm just talking from my
perspective like
no you're right i think i think what i
would do things need to change on a
societal level for example
the guys need a me too kind of movement
where one person says yeah men too
yeah
meant to like one person drops it and
then this guy's you know what i'm saying
if that happens and
women who abuse men start to get shamed
then we can probably get some traction
you know what i'm saying so it needs to
happen that way i'm not saying mentions
just start hitting women they're gonna
happen
yeah just one person just needs to be
brave
well i've never been i've i haven't been
abused
don't need to be abused
you have to be able to send me my own
opinion on this yeah yeah that's true
yeah i feel like for me
i'm kind of like on his side and what
you're saying basically i know as a
boxer you are no woman
no woman should be hitting any man
because i feel like
different people have different
thresholds right so yeah you could hit
someone like yourself you got some
people that um so there's how i i put it
there's three categories of men yeah so
you got the first one which is you
probably fall under that bracket of
if you hit me i'm gonna take
yeah then you got the second layer which
i probably fall under that bracket if
you hit me
i'll probably hit you back yeah but
mine's not on the level of like what's
number one what's number one number one
is you you you have the thing to just
walk away you have to understand how the
hell take the l get punched depending
whatever then you got the second
threshold which is
okay cool
you might hit someone you know someone
if someone hits you your natural nature
that's him that's probably the level i
fall off i was the third one the flood
level is
once they're same guys once they see red
they see red
so they're really like you know what i'm
saying sorry guys even even chitchat
they don't they're not taking chicks
yeah
chit chat they're not once they she
wrote him when you said that i'm not
playing no i'm saying he made the point
yeah yeah the second one
i'm saying
some people when that happens they have
the time to oh oh come back to their
senses then you've got people once that
red is red
they're not stopping until they're
satisfied that you know what
i'm comfortable with
now you understand so which means some
some people might not come back some
people might some women might end up in
the hospital right or whatever
my advice is always
don't put your hands on anybody
myself you don't put your hands on
another human being like you understand
it's not you don't do it so if me as a
man know like okay cool there might be
some people i might feel like okay cool
physically i look like i can say i still
know within myself
because i don't do that so i'll ask you
a question go on
knowing
that women
are like
naturally more emotional
yeah than men right due to
how the body is want to go through all
of that stuff
nature
knowing that though as a man
does that not
so many emotions
we work we don't hit our boss why are
you hitting your man that's true true
she said something you got to remember
yeah
let me respond to that by the same that
you can't that's not a good example
because you're not in a relationship
with your boss
or maybe some people are but anyways but
the point i'm making
yeah but your boss if your boss sleeps
with another woman
that has nothing you're not emotionally
upset about that yeah compared to
your boyfriend or your fiance cheating
on you someone that you've actually got
like an emotional attachment to an
intimate attachment to
cheating on you feel like you're a
grown-ass adult learn how to control
your emotions
you just build differently
yeah
and categorize women they're also men
that
are very emotional
[Laughter]
but women are chemically different every
single day yeah so that's a huge that's
the point i'm making women are like
every day we're chemically different
like that's why you're like i mean [ __ ]
why are you crazy today honestly
all right that's what i'm saying which
is fine but like you still as a girl
should be able to control your emotions
to the point you're not gonna hit a dude
like i just think there's no like
just imagine if you are so
black
don't tell me i'm to stay in my point my
thing is like you know like how women
you guys love to build this future like
you've seen this is it i see this guy
i'm 100 years old we're there
you know like you know what i mean i'm
dead
can i all of a sudden right let me let
me make one key point it's over what's
going on one key point over guys
guys can cheat on you and still love you
by the way
wait girl it's hurting poe
i'll just say one key point i know this
woman is not gonna lie
don't get me wrong
it doesn't have to be over if you don't
want it to be by the way like because a
guy can cheat on you and still love you
like i don't know very much i feel like
some women now that's a whole different
topic like that's something we have to
dive into properly but before we get
there i'll say one thing yeah probably i
will say that people only do what they
know they're going to get away with oh
my god shake my hand that's true i'm
shaking i've taken everybody's hand
that's don't worry but that makes it
worse though no no
i'm just saying that a woman only hit
you if she knows she can get away with
it like you're not going to hit a bat
you're not going to hit that rule you
know what i'm saying so
we need to factor that in when we're
discussing this so are you trying to say
more men need to be more savage reader
no i'm not saying savagery but you need
to be able to control your situation at
home yeah you're right yeah yeah what
amber has heard said on the voicemail
she said go and try and tell the world
that has been abused because she knew
that she knew that he's not on it
can i say something in terms of that
yeah because we we all have to put our
hands up here
as i said i feel like like he said
people do certain things that they know
they can get away with yeah we're all
guilty of that in different aspects of
course
okay cool i can be late to the podcast
nothing could happen about it i wasn't
happy together
all right i can't be late to work
because the more i get laid to work what
happens your pay or whatever yeah your
manager
yeah yeah so i'll get fired i think
that's the same setup that obviously
they've built around right
westernized countries yeah which is our
men are more powerful whatever
women we need something more protection
now we're just to the point where it's
too far
like believe all women like what is that
that's that's what's going on now so you
can't because let's be rude that
wouldn't happen in nigeria no a lot of
women won't get away with africa
it won't happen
to the viewers why it's different so
people understand it's different in the
sense of like there's no law in place
that really protects
that i'm not saying it's right but
people kind of know what they need to do
even to go further than that even the
police officer you're calling yeah beats
his wife so
he's just going to laugh at young girls
i'm saying it's the right thing but what
i'm saying it's the way he delivered
that
i'm just
if you want to talk about like africa
like nigeria and stuff like that like
the dynamics over there is different
because you're in a society where
men essentially the provider yeah women
that we still live you know like
uk or western world might be 20 years
ahead but they're still their mentality
and the way they do things they have a
way of life over there where
where like men are like the ultimate
provider women are just meant to be at
home
look after the kids and raise a family
right which to i'll be honest with
that's a different conversation but i
don't totally disagree with the dynamic
but in the sense of what they what the
guys are saying is that
the
the power dynamics and the level of
protection that women have in the
western world you don't really have that
in africa so it's like the police
officer is a normal guy probably he's
beating his wife at home as well well
that when they step out line up for
whatever reason so it's like
you call the police of oh you know the
wife's calling i'm getting beaten let me
explain let me explain you're gonna come
here but yeah but he could probably yeah
like
um obviously i'm nigerian i mean
yeah yes sir yeah we can tell
the thing is nigeria is
i can't speak for every african country
in nigeria right it's um
we can say it's kind of like a lawless
state
now
um woman abuse domestic violence it's
not it's not accepted it's not an
acceptable thing where you can just beat
a woman and it's accepted right but
unlike here unlike here okay where it's
there's the uh believe it woman uh
movement oh okay and things like that
that's doesn't fly and i it doesn't fly
in nigeria
if
if you if
if a man just randomly
beats a woman right
now you can get into trouble but also
you might not get into trouble
yeah yeah yeah yeah no literally i'll
break it down break it down he's right
so
i come from a country where wealth
really rules depends on your your status
where wealth really rules right and it's
a very loyal state like here
in the western world like uk
america women like he said women know
certain things they can't get away with
right in like nigeria
you can't get away with it you hit the
man
except he decides not to hit you back
yeah you could it's he's not going to
decide not to hit you back because he
might get he might go to jail that
that's not the reason why yeah he might
not retire he's been a nice guy
because he's a knight he might not
retaliate because he's a nice guy or he
just looks at you as fragile
not because oh he feels like if the
police comes i'm going to go to jail
he can knock you the f out
the police who come help you from the
floor and you'll give them money and
then the case is dropped well that's the
that's the problem will be excuse me
the problem in the west is they've taken
away the consequences for women like we
can do damn near anything anything
there's no consequence
and that's what we've seen like in the
past couple years with the me too
movement everyone just took her word she
didn't even go
like i think it's crazy that people were
dropping him and she didn't even go to
court she just said something like yeah
like if i got if i got abused i'm taking
that man to court right now
why do you think that's happened why do
you think the mewtwo movements come
about because girls like the attention
and the sympathy they get
that was what sorry oh that that part
sorry i mean i think the me too movement
like there were girls that had valid
complaints yeah that's correct i think
there were valid but there were girls
that just wanted attention and sympathy
that took advantage of it
and so then the the companies just like
to be safe we're like let's drop this
one
okay okay okay
because we don't we don't want it to hit
our pockets it's just about negative
and then you had the crazy left where
they're just talking like believe all
women da da da da we're gonna
and and the other problem is 70 to 80 of
consumer buying decisions are made by
women
you know what's so annoying about this
situation here well i i think personally
i would prefer to deal with some some of
these situations back in africa um
reason being here because even
here the bad thing about the setup here
is yeah all right fine
your woman decides to abuse your home
all the time yeah
you can't even rally around like a group
of women
to deal with her you understand okay me
as a man i'm not gonna touch you but
i'll get somebody that's on the same
physical level as you to deal with you
you can't even do that because you can't
get them
do that she can also go and press
charges and said oh they've hit me this
and
it becomes something else what happened
to your legs
it's not about legs no no no no let me
let me explain something to you
sometimes it's not about legs it's about
sometimes somebody needs to be taught a
lesson
it's not about legs because okay you run
she she's going to try that to the next
man he runs he becomes a generation of
runners
so you want to be the guy
to be the one to teach her a lesson like
he said we need to something so we i am
good i don't want to sit in jail i don't
want to stay in joe like him smiling
but what i mean is yeah sometimes
somebody needs to be taught a lesson
yeah and in order to teach uh okay
because
you you look look at the end of the day
we have different viewpoints here and
you
from knowing me for so many years i just
felt like you're just a strong
individual yeah but not everybody's like
that so because it's easy for you to
walk away you're fine with that not all
of us have that that mental capability
remember what i said i said i never i
don't disagree with what you guys are
saying i just told my mom but what i'm
saying to you so at what point does this
person get taught a listen you can't do
it through the law like what what do we
do they just keep on abusing men and
just getting away with that
yeah
he's starting to hit the vicious
movement
hit the bitch's movement
yes
wait you need to make that into a
t-shirt look at it on this channel
[Laughter]
actually talking about that do you guys
think that's the problem though because
you know i don't know if you if you work
for an organization or you have your own
business knowing that for example like
what when a t-shirt hit the [ __ ]
it's either not going to get you no
clients or your boss is seeing that i'm
like um we need to have a million here's
your p-45 like what's going
[Laughter]
is more likely
i'm just saying if a girl is coming at
you like i used to i used to think you
should never hit a woman yeah
yeah i have said this until i saw the
types of shots these women be thrown
i could do you didn't expect to take it
like
she threw a bottle at me pearl can you
imagine well you dodged it though
all i know is i don't want to be part of
a generation of runners so i'm ready
i don't want to hit no [ __ ] but i
just don't want to be a generation of
runners in it i already you teach me
doing the running what are we supposed
to do it's not wrong what's the answers
all i say to men is first thing to do if
you start getting into one
always just bring out your phone
and start recording thank you
that's the most sensible thing you just
said right today no he said no it said
no uppercut no no no no no no no
no wait
i have a friend one of my closest boys
back in uni he got into
a coma from his girl um
they got into an argument in his
apartment and she used um
she used something from the kitchen to
smash it on his head
the ambulance came that's crazy mind you
international students wow
students so imagine getting your parents
getting a call all through nigeria yeah
girlfriend girlfriend now parents that
are that are old elderly they start
panicking
you know
and this same this same guy who's the
same same guy my friend he has um he has
a child now
he sent me a video which i have
uh
they
got into an argument right and she was
current she was carrying
his child
the baby and she was holding a knife and
she was like ranting around what wait
let me finish she was ranting ranting
ranting and he you know
he was she didn't know he was taking a
video because she was ranting ranting
that oh i'll do this to you i'll do this
and she had the baby in her in the arm
with the knife in the other arm and he
was out he was standing standing at her
back and was videoing me that oh yeah
you do this yeah and she was you know
going off going off then she looked back
and she saw that he
was recording he was recording
and she was like i'm going to tell the
police that you tried you were beating
me and my son
and then she changed it and the thing is
when when the police come many neighbors
call the police
only woman has to do especially if you
are with a child all you have to do is
start crying
men are seldomly heard but you're
speaking to my point no no so so what
i'm saying is
in in okay see the first case where this
first scenario where his ex hits him
with something and he went into a coma
she the girl didn't go to oh no yeah
yeah yeah now imagine it was the other
way around
and at first she was first hitting her
he was trying to um
defend himself try to defend himself
yeah because he's very calm so he was
like you know what
he was it was in his apartment it was
like [ __ ] it like you can have the
apartment he was leaving so but it was
when he turned around he now used to
smash on his head and he just slipped oh
he didn't walk fast enough now now
imagine if it was the other one now
imagine if it was the other way around
he would have been in jail yeah
so imagine if he was while defending
himself he got angry because of all
these slaps and he punched her would you
say you'd still be in jail as well
that's fine
i know the type of person well
the type of energy i give
you know you can't even play with me
like that come on jay
you can't even try it but
but you can't hit a man and hide in your
femininity you can't hit the people they
want to hide them
i'll be female don't do it to me if i
don't hit you back it's not doing you a
favor come on don't expect i agree with
that as well do not expect
me that you shouldn't put the hat you
shouldn't put the imagine to put his
hand on his female on the female you
know
dude you should expect you take it i
agree you've said something and you're
saying something as well hide behind
your femininity because
there are certain things that women get
away with that men get killed for by the
way that men get that
men are not that um
simple men are not that don't have
sympathy yeah presenting things to other
men
they don't men don't know you get killed
for certain things you will get killed
so i was saying certain things to a man
like i make a point to you though yeah i
feel also that is there's a certain
groups of men as well as breed
the way for behaviors like this to
fester yeah i'll tell you why because
certain man right they find because the
truth of the matter is
like what you you said at the very start
right there are different types of women
there are women that regardless what the
situation is
like yourself
they know how to either walk away is
what it is or i'm gonna take him back
wherever he bought right getting to that
point of putting your hands under the
they're not that kind of person right
however
i genuinely believe that
you
know the truth marriage you know the
type of person you're getting with is
capable of doing this but because i
genuinely believe that my my personal
self because but however when you're
going through that
dating stage everything is still new
you're in love you're doing all of that
you ignore the signs all the little
signs that they're throwing at you that
are showing you that i am capable of
going here you find it as a you it is a
turnout for you
slightly abusive behavior is a turn-on
i'm telling you
wait wait you're going to tell me you
you've never had back in it oh i like oh
she's feisty i've never been in like but
for me personally i'm more reserved so
i've never been into that personally no
no no no even if you're not into that
you're going to tell me you've never
heard the mandems like bro coming up
yeah
some guys do like conversations
let's have a real conversation
that i've noticed that likes girls that
are mean yeah yeah yeah
i've noticed though it's because he
didn't have like the structure growing
up and maybe he had like a meaner like
mom yeah maybe that was or yeah like
like not in the picture at all it's
called trauma i'm not looking for that
but the point i'm making is don't try to
make something i'm just saying some
random stuff
can i say something
when you're fully like deep into that
relationship
and all of that smoke screen has gone
out you know that that first you know
love all of that stuff starts to clear
out you're now starting to see
oh this thing that used to be cute
before
it's a madness is it madness i disagree
like yeah you could disagree but i'm
telling you
if man i'm gonna be i don't
because there are some people who are
into that kind of stuff but it's more
likely the other way around what do you
mean what do you mean i feel like
it's more women that ignore those red
flags than men you know what i mean like
even in my situation
trust me this person you'd never think
would have fly but just one day by the
way they just saw messages and then they
oversee exactly they just got over
emotional and decided that they wanted
to throw throw bottles and stuff let me
tell you something everybody has that
energy inside them yeah it doesn't
matter you can hurt a flag
it's about the individual who brings out
of them no i agree that's the point i
understand i don't think so i believe so
i don't i genuinely i think what do you
think paul you can't propose no you
never no i've never been in a fight ever
oh my god
like i just
why do you think that is for you
i didn't grow up like that i was gonna
say i'll bring you i
just didn't grow up like that and i've
never really been in a situation
so you think do you think it has a lot
to do with your upbringing and stuff
yeah if you grew up around violence
you're more likely to be
the opposite
what you could actually be non-violent
because
you seem to and then you actually don't
want that yeah you're completely the
opposite oh yeah
it can go that way too but i just say
you're more likely likely if you grew up
or with a dysfunctional family that is a
fact yeah it's kind of like it's like
johnny depp talked about that
like wasn't his dad abuse yeah
they're both like both of their parents
amber and yeah his and his parents were
both abused so they just yeah
they're just gonna get back together i
forget this whole thing happened
love overtakes all right say that again
[Laughter]
love is enough
they're gonna get back together and
forget this whole thing happening
but go on um i'm gonna take a break
really quickly we're gonna read super
chats
um jump i'm going to read the ones at
the bottom and then you tell me
sometimes they disappear on my phone
guys okay so we got one from the spoken
one boys are taught to not hit girls
because they are stronger why aren't
girls taught not to hit boys because hit
boys two equal rights and equal laughs
defend yourself
come on um the next one brian woodbridge
amber heard wasn't just wasn't raised
right the little narcissist just needs a
spanking to go to bed without dinner
um
ryan reynolds you sent me money not even
no message i appreciate the people like
you you're just donating to donate thank
you thank you
um vic
quinones um as a man as a man you're
damned if you do damned if you don't you
ask me it's better to stay single the
current dating market is modern women
are the issue um and then
vic queen quinn
whatever i'm sorry
um there's only one place amber heard
belongs she belongs to the street
she belongs to the woman
she belongs to the world
come to the london streets
so okay so next question i have and i
kind of brought this up in the beginning
but i kind of want to go back to it okay
so
when do we just like when does a girl
face jail time for this stuff let's go
because she didn't technically
say his name right she didn't
maybe it's possible that he did hit her
back right that's possible we don't we
don't know like there's no bruises
there were bruises
on her yeah
i don't i don't know if she did or she
did it right i mean i think she's crazy
right yeah but i think johnny cap also
dipped his hand in paint and wrote on
the wall
after he got his finger chopped off oh
my gosh
that's crazy this guy is crazy that's
crazy he was moving but he did admit
that yo i'm like
great
he's a crazy guy that's not an excuse
he got his finger chopped off by her
and then like a normal person would just
go to like
which he did but no it's crazy i'm
saying like not
he's crazy on his part but not like for
him to be he's still the victim
regardless of that in that situation
yeah yeah yeah i'm team johnny oh yeah
yeah
but i'm saying let's say he did hit her
like like yeah being abused all the time
yeah is it possible that he ever hit her
back maybe probably yeah yeah so let's
just say devil's advocate yeah yeah it
did yeah yeah so she she wasn't lying
technically
um she could have been but like she just
removed the whole other side of the
story and you see this with girls is
they'll be like oh he did this this this
this but doesn't talk about like what
would you do yeah what did you do no but
i think i'd go with sokali's point like
i'll go with this point uh from earlier
yeah which is the fact that half the
truth and that's like
the most important part
of the shilajit story but she didn't
press charges against him right she
didn't say his name so does she deserve
she does deserve jail time why and i'll
tell you why she deserves jail time
because and this this this might be a
little bit of personal story but i
shared it on our podcast so i'll share
it here so back when i was younger i got
uh i mean can i talk about this on your
yeah is it cool yeah yeah i got i see
you're lying yeah it's my life
so
my camera i was like 15 16 and basically
i just woke up to this the the like what
are they called like
coordinators she was basically like
sexually abusing man like just
going raggle on me yeah and literally i
froze right now number one i did not
think of reporting it to even my closed
circle because like men i never believed
and even if we all believe the boys are
gonna clown you like come on like why
wouldn't you like that you got something
there wait what was that what she did to
you
what's she doing she's right i haven't
really looked at you oh man
i don't think we should be laughing
about this like that's not funny so the
point i'm trying to make is
if i now choked her because i just found
her on top of me yeah she would go and
say
but she won't tell them why i abused her
because i just woke up to you violating
me do you know what i mean and then on
further up to that the point is i'd
probably go to jail
for the you know the abuse but then
she'll walk free for what she did to me
so when i see amber thing like obviously
i'm sad if johnny depp did retaliate but
also speak on what you did to make him
don't just tell half of the story and
for that purpose i believe she deserves
to go to jail whether or not she because
she you're ignoring the fact that that
she didn't report him nobody pressed
charges she wrote on op-ed and literally
you were just married to the guy you got
a restraining order everybody everybody
knows who you're that the law everybody
knows you're talking did you go to jail
she did something worse though she took
away his livelihood literally
that's like that's the thing
man she doesn't do it exactly
and she chopped his finger off
his fingertips
did the fingers come off are they still
on with some yeah because it sounds mad
yeah did they actually go there are they
gone what's going on it was like the
bone was sticking out like yeah one of
the things so he's got his fixed he's
still got his fingers does it matter
what's the nuances why does it matter
can you still do that
got a weapon and she used it on him like
that's
that's enough
that's enough you know what i'm just d
give your opinion
give your opinion
i really want to break this down you
give your opinion we'll go around you go
first go on on what on this whole
jail yeah
i'm so disappointed yes
okay
yes i'm worried okay cool 100
jail or psych ward
yeah one got trauma
she needs something she should she
should go to jail
yeah definitely tell me a minimum right
right
rikers i hear a lot of scarred men here
um yeah i think any any any situation
where there's blood there has to be some
sort of charge
blood for blood no no no pay it back in
blood no not pay black and blood don't
get it back in blood i'm just saying as
long as there's blood
there should be a charge like the police
have to get involved somebody should get
charged that's that's that's how
yeah poop
[Laughter]
wait a minute
she did what bro she pooped in the guy's
bed okay she didn't who has the most
details do you have the details on
illustration can you break it down dna
test there's nothing to break down
break it down please what actually
happened with the poop situation
you've done the dna
i'll tell you what happened so basically
i don't know if they're in the middle of
a fight or what
no no no no no
he was gone
and then he gets a call from his
security and he's like there's poop on
the bed
and the security like shows him a
picture of it and then she's like oh it
was the dogs but it's like these little
chihuahua looking things they're like it
wasn't yeah that's
never that big
word i'm with you
yeah yeah she needs to be on a straight
jacket she checked in bro
yeah and uh i'm just trying to see when
so she wrote the op-ed in 2018 it's
20-22 so she took half a decade of this
man's livelihood oh nah she needs to get
wrapped for that raptor
not beating up raps i mean as if she
needs to go yeah she needs to sit down
she's like yeah quickly because i don't
think prison will rehabilitate her
because remember i think she's a psychic
when you take somebody's rehabilitator
we can't just mess her up completely we
should try to rehabilitate her because
she might come and mess up on that poop
on someone else's bed yeah but
gel doesn't solve the problem
i think 99 like she's what
37. it's all to change
37 you're gonna stop doing what you've
been doing the last 37 years i'll say
i'll say one thing
i was having a conversation with my
little sister today and i was explaining
to her that
whenever someone does something crazy or
out of character you need to try and
find out why
why it's such a key word and i feel like
we don't give people opportunity to find
out why do you understand she might have
some deep trauma like that poop thing
might have happened to her
you might be dead yeah
no man we're in a safe space right run
yeah no your legs if things happened
it's in a safe space right now let's
break it down and find out why she
pooped in a man's head that's a little
bit why she feels comfortable
i don't think
like who cares why that's what i'm
saying
you know what that's probably why i got
stabbed and
no it's not a while you know what i'm
thinking there's a big
thing we're missing yeah i feel like
once the respect is gone
it's gone
out the window how do you lose respect
for someone like johnny depp
are you in their beds what does that
mean
you don't know that's what i'm saying
you know sexually with him what does
that mean
i think what's the respect it's gone
it's gone anything goes
from poop to peace
[Laughter]
something's pending speaking of speaking
of truth he's traumatized he's a world
boy his master's like crazy
i'm just thinking like someone pooped in
my bed
knocked up
he's a fighter
like when you said we have to know the
why right i don't think i think certain
things are just
no one says like you just want to do
something crazy to piss the person off
so i don't think it's a
let's uh know the why i think it was
just sporadic and
some people you know did you agree yeah
did you agree what's the word
okay okay do you do you
if she gets out she gets out of jail
yeah okay or out of the psych ward let's
let's say she gets psycho are you trying
to live next to her of course not it's
okay so wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait okay
i'll tell you something again i'll say
exactly what i just said ten minutes ago
people don't just do things for no
reason no one does things for no reason
even if it's sporadic or not okay
there's got to be something behind it i
i want to believe that there's something
behind it
let's get to that and understand why
people are there
i think no i think people sometimes do
things because they know there's no
consequences
by saying oh let's figure out the why is
it another way you're just taking away
consequences from women
if a dude beats up on a girl nobody's
saying well why did he do it by the way
guys i agree with what you just said
yeah but you can still ask why and still
dish out
prison
you can still give someone prison yeah
but don't try and not figure out why so
because i'm visiting
while she's on the journey i'm not
saying i'm not saying sympathy right
sympathy and why are two different
things of course yeah sympathy is ah
let's just ignore what happened then
just brush it under the carpet why is
let's dig deeper and see how we can stop
it from happening again closure and
that's more important bro well i just
think it's because you're a bad person
uh yeah
no
[Laughter]
you did it because you're not a good
person okay but why are there a bad
person why they might went through
something i can't justify there's a lot
of people that go through [ __ ] and come
out good people by the way she went
through [ __ ] came out of a bad person
and now she's selfish
and self-centered so you don't you don't
believe me
rehabilitation that's the key question
say some people can do it young but most
people don't certain age i think most
like think your childhood friends
most of them are how they are
by the way
by the way
like and if they made a change it was
probably young
37 no no
okay so you want us to sit amber her
down and be like why did you [ __ ] in my
bedroom
so now we asked amber amber says you
know what i shot in his bed because you
know when i was in college my my one of
my roommates she sat in my bed because i
used her makeup okay okay so now what do
we do that information all right
like what do we do
why is that a shitty person it brings in
closure
no it's not about closure it's about it
okay
okay amber i've heard that you got your
bed got shattered before so you think
it's acceptable to share someone else's
bed
but
here's a intervention crew
we're going to explain to you look it's
not acceptable to [ __ ] in bed you're
moving man that one you must not [ __ ] in
bed
i do believe i want to believe that
there is um what's the word i don't even
know the english word for it but you can
you know rehabilitate you can
rehabilitate rehabilitate yeah but
people have to be willing to do that
okay if they're not willing stay in jail
i mean with this situation she's still
defending yeah this whole situation
she's still defending she still got the
same stance she had
back in 2018 she's still
trying to defend what happened she's not
in court right now saying oh you know
what
like she lied on the oath right how many
times she's not there saying you know
what i lied
back then i'm sorry blah blah so clearly
your point is not no it's not about my
point it's about
if she had come forward and said okay i
lied blah blah blah that's different but
that's not the situation that's what i'm
trying to say if she came forward and
was apologetic and tried to you know
dig deep within herself then let's help
her yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ]
we gotta meet you halfway though yeah
that's the problem
you're halfway i'm meeting you halfway
but we're talking about this amber
girl she hey she's still in court right
now trying to defend i was talking about
real life now oh yeah she can't go to
jail she's gonna say that yeah yeah yeah
fair enough yeah
oh spend 15 minutes to end up
no but i'm just being hypothetical on
what i'm saying let me say something i i
just feel like compared to men
um
a lot of feelings more times women are
not brought to
you know are not brought to justice when
they do something wrong so for example
we've seen cases where a man was accused
of something right and
you know the world wants to finish this
man wants to end this man take away this
take away that zuma right
right so but i'm talking about like in a
man and woman situation so for example i
don't know if you heard the chris brown
situation recently
where the girl
oh yeah so i don't know if you heard
about the chris brown situation recently
where the girl came out and was
accusing chris brown over about the
receipt rape things like that right yeah
yeah on social media i saw everything
people were like ah
he's an abuser yeah bringing up the
rihanna thing it's not gonna work keep
listening to his music this this this
this
until he came until chris brown came out
with receipts came out with text
messages where she was actually
asking him uh when are you free let's
have sex but he kept on like he didn't
answer yeah
and now
the same people are coming on social
media um
you know they don't have anything to say
they disappear those people disappear
equally as loud right yeah yeah that's
right
but listen it's never it's never that
case because now the the situation has
disappeared now she's probably
going on with her life but look at if if
this guy didn't have
receipts yeah everybody that thing could
end his livelihood but it's like i said
earlier
take food out of a man's mouth
food out of his mouth and her and his
ability to feed his family
you have to go to jail now i agree with
you i agree that's the consequence you
have to agree with jail that's another
thing that's what i'm saying why is it
when it comes to accusing a man it's
almost like the man is guilty until
proven innocent but when is that way
around we my man over there said we have
to have video evidence guys
we can never be trusted that's just
society bro no but i feel like they need
to politics obviously
they need to actually change some of the
legislation so when women know that look
if i get this wrong or i get found out
there's like a 10 year sentence waiting
for me because this stuff like that
would come
again guess what again
the bad thing about that is
when women do things like that and are
caught
um wanted right it affects
women that are actually going through
real estate yeah yeah yeah
that
you shouldn't be able to publicly say
that something happened to you unless
you're willing to go to court for it
yeah yeah like i believe this on a
personal level too
because i'll have girls like tell me
stuff happened and i'm not i'm not
trying to be an [ __ ] but i'm like
okay go to court why come here why why
come social media what why did i go to
social media a lot of the times that's
what they do and like the law
it works if well i don't know about i
don't know how the legal system works
here but in the u.s like like the law is
on your side
like there
there's evidence like you can go through
the process it works because typically
if a dude's doing that like he has a
pattern of behavior so you might not
work for you but the next like three
four girls like all coming out saying
the same thing
like you're gonna get caught eventually
yeah yeah if you're just but if you're
just being quiet then like one that
hurts the next girls when they come
forward yeah
so like i just put your money where your
mouth is go to court and that's the
thing i think even like you
i agree with the point you're making
because what we've seen as a culture of
not just women a lot of people run
social media the court of social media
yeah just find it on the blogs this guy
did this and this he finessed me you
know what's that guy called on netflix
that finessed all these women tinder
swings tinder
ah he got financed on me to the like go
to the police what can we do on social
media for you it's not sometimes the
police don't do anything no it's not i
feel like now it's double like people
who go to social media then when they're
gone at the right the right number of
attention
then go to police it's crazy when they
even posted that oh guys i've now gone
i've now gone to the police it's
actually the maddest thing to do
but we're in a different world now i'm
telling you it's crazy now point we're
in a different world now i also feel
like people on both sides shouldn't be
named
until
yeah
yeah until they're guilty yeah
and why don't we take science before the
evidence yeah let's come out emotion
because people people like if you've had
similar experiences right in the
once you hear like remember especially
when you if you have similar experiences
either you've it's gone on
unsolved or on like you've not received
the right justification right or you've
actually gone through it and you have
received the right remember you're
always going to be sensitive to that
experience so as soon as you hear
or get the woof of like somebody else is
going through similar you're like there
to the rescue very true oh yeah
get him away and get him out
so people like never really let go of
their trauma but i i sometimes i think
it's there's a group of women that just
hate men yes
whenever they get the chance they're
just like ready to like take again it
comes from somewhere though like what um
tetz was saying before like i just said
now like they've been through stuff like
where they're scarred for life i don't
think so so you think there's women that
have not been through nothing and
they're just like
what do you think it is you live in this
society that's like it's a gynocentric
social order like everything is
pro-woman
that word was a bit money
centric social order so everything you
see is marketed towards women so seventy
to eighty percent of consumer buying
decisions are because women are made by
women so all the companies are marketing
towards women the media is marketing
towards they're pandering to women yes
and so i never knew that yeah
yeah and so it's like like their whole
lives like were catered to in my opinion
so do you think that there are women
that see that gap and then they just
want to just play they want to play that
so they can get come up i mean i
i just think it's it's just like the men
are trash generation and don't give me
they might have one or two situations
but i i know girls like that have
actually been through [ __ ] okay you got
cheated on by your high school boyfriend
boo hoo move on
like again nobody has died go over it
what what do you think about that
actually like with the the whole men out
trash situation and
do you think women are taking advantage
of that right now or do you think it's
justified
i think when it comes to social media
like like crow was saying that if you
can say it on social media i think you
should be able to say it okay say it in
court but then there's some people
obviously that don't say it on social
media that have been abused or whatever
the situation is and are not
able to speak or don't
feel
ready to speak because then you do have
people who come out here and
lie about their situation so then they
think oh they're not going to believe me
like this happened to me or sometimes i
think when people have interviews
sometimes you don't have the evidence
either i think that's a key part that's
a key part sometimes you're not going to
have evidence so it's just like how how
is somebody going to believe me right
but more likely yes like they're going
to believe a woman before a man yeah
like the talent's always been but do you
think women are taking advantage of that
fact hundred percent they'll believe
homophobic i think some women are yeah
i'm not gonna say all but i don't know
society like the the
the um overwhelming
majority i think they're taking
advantage of it through social media
like a lot like you hear
a whole bunch of stuff all the time and
social media portrays like false like i
say like false advertisement false
narratives
for people people fake their lives all
the time through yeah facts facts
are like and there's something really
called the cult of social media though
it's foreign
to add to that right i'm telling you
right now people talk about false and
whatever is the false is now becoming
the reality that's the fact about it
because
once social media there's so many
scenarios if you look online properly in
so many different situations that's
happened that
police didn't care about they've thrown
it away but once social media like i
said gets involved and they get the
right out the right number of outrage
and wherever police then start to take
it serious it's almost like they're now
being dictated to
by the people which is crazy that's true
i'll build a platform off of being a
victim 100 as well yeah there's money
involved in that you guys remember hurt
me
yeah you became a phenomenon just
because i mean you don't know like which
is crazy like
literally you can build a platform
you know one thing that is crazy like
with this amanda thing if she comes out
to be guilty
it's going to set the love women back
also if this uh megan the stallion thing
comes out that she's lying
so you're talking about what the man
there's a trajectory for a win for men
2020 taking this l they're taking this
line like but the thing is also
because these things affect women that
are actually going through
real life live situations and they're
taking away from it you're taking away
from that so real jail time for both of
them to be on the real talk both of them
yeah now not real talk
uh i i think we just need to start a
movement bro like me too a man two men
too
obviously i i can't lead the the the
movement why but because i haven't had
the pearls leading up it's not i think
paul you should be the the men to
treat me hit the [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm not involved head back
this would be the advocate for him
advocate you don't have to go through
something to be able to it's just about
doing what's right what's right is right
and what's wrong with wrong it's just
important
i do hear that i don't understand that's
what it is i do here
yeah
okay so that's in your hands then you
must start
i think it's actually like i think it's
happening i think it's happening i don't
think it's happening i think it's
happening like i'm on socials it's not
happening it's happening little by
little it's happening but with these
high-profile cases
if the women have found guilty it's
going to change a lot of things
can i say why also you go first fast
like i feel like the high profile cases
are just a representation of what's
happening all throughout society if this
is happening to johnny depp how many men
does this happen to right
men get three times the same
um the sentencing for the same crime
yeah i agree with it
i agree with what you've both said the
same crime but what i'll say to you is
the reason why this will never actually
properly take off is because
we don't take it seriously enough like
how much laughs have we had about this
serious topic bro yeah people find the
[ __ ] funny
i mean no one's gonna take it seriously
that's what i said it's happening little
by little it is
when something is high profile
there's nothing that happens that that
there's nothing that happens that that
is high profile that doesn't change
something when something is high-profile
enough there's a glitch that happens
something changes i hate you something
is bound to change all the media around
this thing right has been comedy like
what did that as soon as i saw you today
what was we laughing about the fact that
the lawyer was saying i objected to my
own question but that's what you think
we just find jokes about that's why you
think if you go on youtube there are a
lot of um platforms talking about it a
lot of major platforms talking about it
there's this guy does this guy um
subscribe to um he's an american lawyer
he breaks down cases i can't remember
yeah yeah i know you talk about yeah
yeah you're talking about the lead
attorney yeah
yeah fresh and fit too everybody's
talking about even kevin samuels
big joe bunning podcast everybody's
talking about it right so
it's growing steady steadily because a
lot of men have suffered a lot of guys
having jail time i really like
i'm really um when i talk about these
things like
i'm really passionate about things like
this because it happens i've seen it
happen before
and men are really listened to it's just
the fact so when things are changing now
it might not happen immediately but
things that things will be better than
before i agree with what you're saying
even if when you look like i mean i
won't touch on it deeply even if you
look at the whole tory meg situation
right a lot of people are speaking out
loud where they wouldn't you wouldn't
expect them to normally i thought
everyone was going to keep quiet and say
yeah meg we love you we're with you but
you see a lot of people speaking out and
saying
until we get to the trial yeah
let's just wait to see what happens and
that showed me that
we are changing small smoothies like not
everyone's just jumping what happened
with that i don't actually know what
happened with mike the stallion i really
like it okay so there's a lot i'll try
to break it i said there's a lot no you
go ahead yeah you break it down
from what i know what i read um they may
or may not have been doing a mad thing
um sexually um allegedly he also was
doing the same thing with her best
friend kelsey um and then they went out
they were drinking they were kylie's
party yeah and i think meg found out
allegedly i don't know allegedly that
they were dealing and then they argued
and then she liked to leave in the car
in the car and then allegedly
he shot her in the foot
when she got it when she got the car
because he didn't want her to leave so
she was looking the other way by the way
let me break it down
yeah i mean basically if i was listening
to
this guy dj academics um
um twitch thing and he's cool with um
tory
so he was saying he was breaking it down
like he said um
sorry ladies was
he had been smashing um what's her name
meg
[Music]
he was
he was talking to her best friend right
he was talking to her best friend and
apparently
meg has um she has a reputation for
um you know
smashing people in the industry right
yeah this is our cause academics just
said she's a whole storyline told him
right that she's um she's got a
reputation for that and
she
mega smashed
a couple of guys that her best friend
have has had
interesting
so
her best friend and tory lanez were
talking they were talking for a while
and oh my god
[Laughter]
so she started smashing today this is
the third person so our friend was
pissed off like what the [ __ ] like why
is it every guy
i'm interested in i'm talking to you
kids trying to let me come up smashing
right so they go into an argument and um
they're going to an argument and um
kylie jenner kicked them out of
the party of the party no they don't
know i'm not all about this the
kardashians don't play no they got an
argument in the car
and you know this and this and if you
see the video of when she was outside
the car and the police um you know they
came with the helicopter helicopter yeah
she was bleeding from her foot
um
academic said she wasn't shot today that
she was she was drunk and she was
getting angry and she
she stepped on a glass box oh yeah she
hits the glass of the car window and you
know
sliced her leg and that was where the
bleeding was coming from but i don't
know if you've seen her her recent
interview one
about the intercourse the sexual
relationship she started she stuttered
but wait would you not start off if your
story lanes they were accusing you of
sleeping with short as he is no but i'll
be real with you yeah the the part that
baffled me that when the whole thing
came out yeah the part that i was just a
bit hmm there's a question mark over the
whole thing but the part that for me was
like
like within two days
she was bought and she was working like
twerking again on stage well like if you
got a shot right in your foot yeah like
you got a cold that got shot in his leg
you got boosted i got shot in his legs
there was no [ __ ] for a while you
got shot in your foot and you're
twerking in three days
close range like i don't make it she was
working two days later yes yes she was
talking to you wow that's a dedication
to being a hunter
no really so that for me was like a big
question you think about it i mean
speak on it
because
i mean honestly like there's his side on
her yeah nobody knows what happened
people can say this dude that happens
right nobody knows right unless you were
there right so you have to wait till the
facts come out yeah right but should she
go to jail true if she was wrong
not guilty
yeah i think so if she did lie and she
lied about him shooting her yeah like
that's crazy it's crazy in it like and
it gives like women that don't do that a
bad rap yeah because then you have guys
like getting all angry at women you like
these
angry men and like the girls that don't
do [ __ ] we're like what do we do
and one thing men need to stop doing as
well
you know
i'd come across on this um
can you see yeah yeah you've caused bad
times so you might as well now don't
stop now yeah guys okay let me know let
me just you know guys need to stop doing
something guys need to stop um
immediately a guy is accused of
something
guys need to stop
just chill and listen to
you know both parties men need to stop
instantly wearing the captain save the
whole cape you know i don't know
when when did sorry lynch thing came out
when they came out um there were a lot
of rappers that came out and were like
they
now that things are looking like
she was lying the guys are quiet now
very quiet they're quiet now they can't
talk but to answer your question it goes
back to the guy next door
what she said
that's what i'm saying
yeah like sometimes i wonder why don't
guys have more like you guys
yeah like more camaraderie but are they
trying to get laid do you think i'm not
no do you know what is is a hate in fact
that men have i genuinely believe and
that though and that though what's that
we want women to like us you know what i
mean so even
even when we are on podcasts when we're
doing our podcast it goes through your
mind that you don't want to go against
the women you don't want to say anything
that's going to antagonize women it goes
through your mind
you don't want to ruin your market it's
a real i mean whatever that market may
be relationship market sexual right it's
a real audience market you don't want to
ruin your money so hence why rory and
mao they must have thinking listen let's
just jump on this because i don't see
how someone gets shot and straight away
you just jump on tour and be like you
haven't even had none of the friends
for me personally i just believe is like
a
embedded thing with with men right like
we're extremely competitive and i think
we're so competitive to the detriment
so in terms of we don't tend to
recognize the sign of when hey we need
to come together and hold it no we're so
competitive like
let's be real if you go back to that
time
tory it was during lockdown
he was doing a madness with his um
currency radio
he was about to go to that next level in
my opinion like he was doing the madness
and i felt like
everybody's sitting back watching that
it was almost like the situation that
the industry could not wait to happen
so as soon as that happened it was
almost like we're down for boom we need
to keep him down now because he was
winning too much
and then and then obviously that's why
obviously i would agree with villa like
if she was um guilty of this
gel straight away because
he's been in the industry and been
working so hard here that i feel like he
needs to be up there and then now i feel
like that just that situation has kind
of kept him where he was
before he was back the torah that we
knew we knew from before he's not gone
past that level now he's still there and
i feel like for him like his work ethic
and his talent is what still kept him
you know relevant right now like chris
brown too yeah
is there a talent
without that
bro i can't then i'll be done out here
very true with that little allegation
that they're done you're gone out here
really that's that's just how i feel
definitely for her i think part of it as
well like from obviously the women's
perspective
once like they feel like someone's
wronged them
anything they can do to just to get you
back live they're doing it if they have
to lie is that true
that's actually you're laughing you're
laughing it's just like there's there
are some girls like what is this how is
it that you two are just going to
completely different
i see like i think
part of being different is like
every girl's a little crazy like i'm not
above like it's just like if you know
you're crazy you're not going to do
crazy [ __ ] you know what i mean
because like if i'm getting emotional
i'll just be like oh i'm just like i'm a
girl i'm being emotional like just give
it a day or two
but like a lot of girls they live in
this like delusion
like
like
and they think like they think reach
they think just because they're angry or
they're mad or they're more emotional
than men they can just do whatever they
want
or or
or they'll blame it on their childhood
which i understand maybe that's why but
like you i'm sorry if you're over the
age of like 21 18
get over it so you feel like everyone
always look when thing goes wrong
everyone always look for that thing
because they don't want to believe that
i'm this horrible so they gotta look for
something to say hey no girls can men
can't like if a dude if a girl hits a
dude she'll say oh like i witnessed
abuse
that's why and that's okay that makes it
okay but but the men if they hit a girl
prison like they're like they don't
what's your excuse yeah
to say no people don't they might say
that but they're not going to get a mic
like they're not going to be given the
platform and i think it's a bit
difficult if a half of her face is
hanging off the side
for anyone to see that hey he was
because i think that's what might be off
the rip like a guy if you punch a woman
her face gonna be like this and i feel
like that's a distraction in itself from
people trying to understand your
perspective i'm like oh my god
look at this woman what
can i say
exercise discernment right i mean i'm
not saying you feel like she slaps your
chest to like decorate
yeah
of course but like there i don't know
there's a difference between a girl like
like
you shouldn't do it at all but there's a
difference between a girl like play
hitting you yeah yeah and the punches
these [ __ ] be throwing
have you been hit before by the one of
these [ __ ] what no remember she's
never been in a fight never been in the
fight i've been in the i mean i played
please
it just changes your whole mindset about
this whole thing the day a [ __ ] punches
you
all of this four persons comes out of
the window i just
i'm pretty good at getting people to
like call like i have people that like
get amped on my show but i don't know
i've never been on this show what is
that on this show yeah i've had people
get like like i'm just like wonderful no
no just like they're more aggressive
i'm like if someone gets mad like i just
still talk to them at the same level but
it might happen one day i hope
i hope not the more i talk maybe
the bigger this gets
yeah
that's crazy
it's crazy i like your perspective on
certain things it's very uh real not
it's not normal
yeah there you go
that's the word it's not because guess
what um which is good a lot of
girls will call you pikmi yeah
[Laughter]
however how do you respond to girls
calling you a pick me yeah i am oh you
just say yeah let's just do it i don't
say this stuff because i don't i believe
what i said yeah yeah
but if you're going to say oh you want
to get picked do i want to die alone
come on no no
you should use this clip and i wrote
the main thing is
guys the main thing is as long as you're
true to yourself what you're saying
that's all that matters right no if you
come out as a pick me you'll pick me
well i grew up i i respect my dad a lot
my dad like i think i call him a little
too much like he wants me to like call
him less
daddy no but i have like nine siblings
and i grew up between two boys so i just
like okay i feel like you can't say men
are trash if like you respect the men
around you and a lot of a lot of times
these girls like didn't have men like
either the dad is like super weak so he
like never stood up for himself so she
didn't respect it yeah kind of like well
like will smith let's talk about it like
like dude they're kids do the kids sound
like they respect well no
when
when they're like talking about how they
wish tupac was here
so you have that dynamic and then you
have the other dynamic where the dad
just like wasn't there but then a lot of
times it goes back to they don't know
why he wasn't there because a lot of
times like men are pushed out of the
kid's life because like men don't really
have rights in court
so it's like they're there's just where
have you been all our lives
write a book or something it's real
that's real well it's just
you listen to men talk like a lot of it
these aren't like i don't make this
stuff up myself like are you serious
that's very good very well raising you
so even that women just
choose to ignore all of those facts that
you are obviously absorbing and
understanding well i think a lot of
girls haven't heard it okay so like i
grew up with a like because my my
personality is very much like
like like left okay and i'm very
conservative and so but like my like my
personality traits if i take a
personality test it puts me at like the
95th percentile left because i'm very
creative i'm open to like the
personality traits that tend to go with
like more liberal people like that's why
if you meet someone that lives in a van
like you assume they're more left yes
and if you meet someone that's like an
accountant you assume they're more right
it's because of the personality traits
that are associated with it but my dad
would just like break every like every
time i'd like want to go that way my dad
would just like break it down
and like eat it i was a little bit more
left in college but my dad would just
like break down every single thing that
would make me want to go that way okay
and so i just think it's really
important for women to be surrounded by
men they respect because otherwise like
like then they have a tainted view of
man
that's very true and i also believe that
a lot of women
they feel the same way
you feel
within themselves they feel the same way
they have the same perspectives you have
but won't
come out and say it
it's it goes there's a culture that
makes many shits cool mm-hmm there's a
man in [ __ ] culture cool
even uh yeah we know that
that man might be right but man
i'm still shy
in you know back in uni
well i i think that's something i think
there's more reasonable women than like
people really especially in this sector
of youtube like bring out like believe
to be honest because i have girls all
the time on my show most of them aren't
ratchet most of them aren't like hate
man-hating but it's just like the ones
that are so loud right and most women
are more agreeable they're not going to
say stuff because like they're they're
just more agreeable and yeah and
my advice to just
men out there that
live in a real world not social media
because again we can easily i've said
this before in our podcast as well like
we can easily just if you're stuck on
social media it's easy for you to think
everyone's opinion is that right where
we're missing the fact that majority of
people
the population probably don't are not
there so something like oh all women are
the only one gold they're they're gold
diggers the only one this or that that
that expectation but
you can whatever level you are in life
whatever situation you are you walk you
can find a woman that can compensate
that and take you to that next level so
i feel like and you have to understand
the media like
even for my show like to be honest i
wish i had more feministy liberal girls
that could come on it's a better show
like
it sounds so sick
because i personally like the battle of
ideas does better it's good
yeah and so if i can find like people
that are like i have girls that i'm
friends with that i'm like you're my
villain come on yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and so it's like
it's you're gonna see it more like i'm
sure fresh and fit do the same thing or
all the male
podcasts they have to yeah it's good
it's good media now you're not really
kicking people off
well that they want that though yeah
because
how much money did they make off of
those videos yeah crazy yeah i'm not
hating on it
like i'm trying to if you guys know any
feminists
i don't know i don't know i know one or
two yeah i would introduce them to you
no don't bring them yeah don't tell them
who i am i'll bring them no we'll talk
though i'm i'm really worried not not
for right now right now right now but
i'm looking like the next 10 20 years
i'm worried for the
upcoming generation like the women
okay because the way
the
society is right now if it keeps going
this way
they're literally creating a divide
between men and women they're putting
you in a position where i remember back
in the days growing up here i don't know
i was like in america like
if i see a girl across the road i'm on
this side right and she's like should
catch me i can jog across the road hey
darling you're right what's your name
where you from did it i can do that you
can't do that i remember growing up you
cannot do that now y'all you're weird or
you're a creep you're this and you're
that and then not really it depends how
good looking the guy is yeah facts
facts i guess
no no but no the ultimate point though
regardless no no no no real talk i'm
telling you like you can that's a good
point but however the fact of the matter
is even now
it's so widespread that even the even if
you're good looking and you're confident
in yourself you're going to think twice
i don't want to be
that guy i don't want to be that guy
said something like that he said would
they have harvey weinstein case like you
know a lot of women came out and we're
like you know having weinstein was
basically being increased yeah yeah but
if it was um um johnny depp johnny depp
or um what is angelina julie's um brad
and it's old and grey then they start
coming out but you know they're they're
safe
though you
i do get your point but i'm just saying
like we can't ignore the fact that even
right now no matter how confident you
are it's just not a thing to do right
because i've never run up to we even had
it on our podcast and we're talking
about i don't know have you heard of
not in hill carnival no
yeah so
yeah i'm not under the rocks
no no carnival is the biggest carnival
in europe biggest street fight is
amazing and back in the day you could
literally just go up to a girl that's
dancing and just go behind her and catch
a wine you know
twice i don't think i don't think you
will think twice okay you make but you i
don't think you would you're still doing
it i think carnival's still out bro yeah
it's still
your life your life be careful what
you're saying in your life
like it's not a new carnival right yeah
everyone's out people the girls want to
want to grind
behind you so it's like i said i'm not
going to just go and group like a creep
but i haven't been been for to in a long
time but you're not going to tell me
things are changing
you're not going to tell me if she turns
around i'm like assault remember there's
police around that's true
what are you doing that's true but
listen are you telling me that most guys
that go that would go to nothing yo
carnival now because obviously the
demographic has changed we're much older
now so but like the people that are like
21 that type of age they're the ones
that will be there
yeah right and we don't know how not in
the carnival is all the girls are like
in the skimpy skimpy
[Music]
most guys right now if they go to
national carnival when they want to
grind with a girl they're not going to
be like hey excuse me they're just
grabbing it
which is what i'm saying in 2022 now bro
that's what i'm saying
that's the point i'm missing the ball
listen because what do you mean advice
don't want to do it there you go check
this out my guy if if she turns on like
i've i've been molested up in um what's
the word gross and whatever it is please
grab you do you think any people was
feeling sorry for you no that's true
yeah
i'm a sex offender but yeah
i don't want that i'm saying i know
carnival every guy that is going up to
your girls
do you know how many people got in
trouble
get into trouble going in trouble recent
in the last one bro the the one before
uh
remember listen listen
about the
extra i'm sorry i'm not talking about
the extra the extra stuff
most guys do not know cannibals even in
the clubs most guys are not really to be
honest are not going to going up to a
gunner like hey if she's if she's
twerking and those guys are trying like
okay go chop a wine then if the girl
looks back and she's like oh he's good
looking i don't mind listen those guys
are not going to be like sorry excuse me
i think you're missing the point that's
why exactly exactly please break it down
bro
i think the point is that men in 2022
are more likely to be called creeps or
being said they're they're assaulted
right just trying to approach a woman or
grab a woman in the club yeah i'm not
i'm not really a twerker i'm more of a
shimmer
yeah i'd be like and you're looking that
way and i came and shimmy behind you
would it be an issue
i need to ask are you touching me
yeah it's like a grind type no oh yeah
[ __ ]
i don't really go to clubs like that
i don't know what's going on
hypothetically hypothetically
hypothetically um hypothetically i've
done guys dance with you i've never
she's waving a white flag no i've never
been a grinder okay it's just not my
thing all right have you been a grinder
yeah okay so if i
i'm the type person
i'll look back and see
what you look like
if i'm like
let me ask you guys
let me ask you a question how many guys
okay
from the times you've gone to the club
right and the times you've given a guy a
wine
how many guys how many
have uh tapped you like hey excuse me
can i get a wine please
that's that's so creepy
no big man
no baby you know what you know what
give me one second give me one second
i'm not i i never disagree with what
you're saying the point i'm making is
that
but bro as a
like guy now that you're
like
proper like you know i mean and you're
really you know what's going on in
society right
you're going to think twice like last
guys it's not like back in the days i do
think i know how wild that was back in
the days like if i see a thing there
i'm gonna
but now bro i gotta think
i'm cool unless she is older a lot i
think like that well i think maybe i'm
old
i just want to go to jail
as a girl like less guys approach me in
2022 than like they did when i was like
16. and that's what i'm worried about in
20 years time i'm like i miss it like
come up to me
abby please sometimes it makes your day
right you might get like 10 people
approaching that day eight of them might
be
douchebag but um
well at least two you can make your day
like i can't believe that guy even come
and chat me up that's gone that's that's
also the problem though in the clubs
it's either you're for it or not for it
you know i mean you can't have like
okay if he's good looking he gets a pass
if he's not good looking
then i'm not on it but that's what
happens
that's what happens that's what happens
though you also have a problem where
girls will like flirt with a guy and
then leave and be like oh my god he's
such a creep i'm like what the [ __ ] what
do you think that is you were just could
you help me
yeah
why do you think that is can the girls
explain that please yes because i need
to know i need to know i've never done
it
[Laughter]
she's
like personally i've never heard a girl
say that either really yeah i never have
oh my god i see girls do it all the time
where they'll be like flirting with the
guy
and then leave i think part of it's
because we're more agreeable we don't
like conflict i think that's part of it
but like
i don't know sometimes i think girls
like like the attention right and then
later they're like ah
try to tone it down yeah i've got the
free attention i'm gonna keep it moving
now yeah i think is currency
yeah i think some guys can be aggressive
though aggressive yeah yeah so like i've
had situations where
he like wanted me to give his number he
wanted dancing but i was like polite
about i was like no i'm like i'm good
i'm okay he came back and was like why
not i was like i'm just not like i'm
okay
and he's like but why and i was like i'm
just i'm just nice
he left and he came back and he was like
he just called me a [ __ ] oh
like grabbed my ass right and then was
like [ __ ] and then just walked off yeah
because he was like an ego thing oh god
he should
more cautious about things yeah yeah so
like i'm more cautious but like you
don't want to you want to be nice about
it because you don't know how men are
going to react
so yeah because i feel like it's men
like that are ruined that's crazy
i heard some situations that happened in
new york some guy um a woman went to the
bodeg the bodega
and um some guy approached her and she
was like nah i'm not interested and he
sh he shot a shot oh yeah
america is a crazy place so i'm sorry
for real this girl was at a corner store
so he was going to pay for her stuff and
she's like no i'm okay like i got it he
got mad so like when she left
all the boy there was three men with him
i think it was three or four they all
like started hitting her one dude like
bit bit her face
yeah yeah i bit her just because she
said no
so it's like it's it's scary because if
you decline them it's actually crazy
that's crazy i don't know i don't think
that's like the norm though that's not
that's that's the thing
that's how crazy i'll tell you something
right stories like that
oh don't give me yeah yeah that's what
breathes right where we are right now
because even me hearing that i'm like
what yeah
and then that's where you get this
empathy like because you just we look at
women are like nah it's meant to be this
thing that's supposed to be protected
right and like yeah like at all cost but
then you find that that these
anomalies that's what i call them these
very anomalies they just do these wild
things and then they get those things
that really get publicized a lot right a
lot anytime like look at the everett
situation right might be touchy but
again
it's like
they i think i was listening to lbc they
were like
men should have a curfew
6 p.m men all men should be home
what what that's crazy was that was i
don't know when i heard that
people talking about there was like
stuff people are throwing stuff like
that out there like nah we need to
change the laws men need to be home by 6
p.m because we need to protect women and
the
because of these anomalies that just
ruins everything for a lot of the good
man i feel like
you should be willing to take rejection
as well
i think men in general take rejection
better than women
i feel like girls they get broken up
with one time they're like still talking
about it like
ellen move on no
it doesn't happen it's like what yeah
like huh i'm gonna read okay guys i want
to read super chats really quick
okay guys um
90 frit
oh my god these names for topee
hey i was watching your show with jess
about elder and dave rubin ask her what
she thinks that all the brutal cops
events happened in blue blue states um
jess is actually out of town for three
weeks but i'll we'll bring that up when
she gets back
um okay i'm so torn my little sister
went through the same thing and i
believe her but i know guys who went
through the same thing and it comes
the same and it comes it's complete lies
it's very sensitive that's from jay yeah
thank you so much
um another super chat
from no name darkness ten dollars no
message i
you guys got me thank you thank you um i
think some disappeared
um so we have jay yah
um
like chris rock said what happened to
just crazy
um we have one more super chat from lost
soul with twenty dollars no message
and guys just you know all super chats
are going towards new equipment we have
a lot of new updates in the studio so
when you guys are sending super chats
i'm not even keeping it right now i'm
just reinvesting it into equipment so
it's all it's like very much appreciated
right now as we're growing a lot and i
know you guys have been
um very much supported and there's one
more super chat that just came in men
who overreact to rejection most likely
weren't raised with the father figure
they are more emotional than most
so
some guys have also watched their
mothers go through stuff
domestic i'm an example that right you
know so that is why certain guys don't
when they hear like a woman has been
domestically abused even if she's lying
they take the woman's side because they
witnessed it before so it's not like a
far-fetched thing i think it's like kind
of like in
like i think men have a protective
instinct that's true towards women
nature true yeah like i don't you don't
just undo that
men i think men naturally protect and
provide
yeah like more so than women yeah
um
so another so another issue um or
another thing that's in the media right
now
have you guys heard the update about kim
kardashian and ray j
yeah yeah what a sex tape coming back
yeah so we're just talking about i was
just looking this up so
rage so right now
let me start over so way back when kim
kardashian got famous because she slept
with ray j and there was a sex tape that
was leaked
and the whole time they've been painting
kim as the victim
the poor girl she
she got you know nailed on camera and
they just let that out
and it was like kind of blamed on ray
jay's side right over here is poor girl
whatever
then you know kim
kind of built a career off this show
it's a reality tv show she now she's one
of the youngest billionaires yeah female
self-made billion like yeah really crazy
cool cool [ __ ] right
and now there's a new episode in the
show where i guess there was a second
tape yeah that came out in the episode
okay and like she was saying and kanye
like
saved her i don't know like
and so
then after this episode came out ray j
screenshots a message to kim
my team is demanding me to respond
to what's out there now because every
day gets worse every day i don't say
anything now that we've talked and i
feel now that we talked i feel different
i was i was gonna go extreme but not
anymore how should i respond she said i
completely understand and i appreciate
hearing this from you i wanted you to
know that i wish nothing but the best
for you this was her this has hurt us
symbol so many ways and i know we are
both we are
aligned and wanting to move forward in
our lives and not continue to be defined
by something that we did 20 years ago
thank you for reaching out to me my hope
is that after next week when everyone
sees the computer was given back to
kanye that the story will be dead and
done with
and then it's like a response to him all
of all of the videos and pictures and
texts from me and you because i was
trying to make things okay and make you
feel better now i realize this is just
another promotion stunt for you unless
you reach out to me i'm gonna take it to
the level where it shows all of what we
did and all of the meetings and
conversations about the plan date times
in our meeting meetings and the whole
lie you and chris planned since the
beginning this is not this is not a
threat you've taken it too far you know
what you did your mom controlled the
whole tape
deal
and it was her idea to put it out
i knew that though
time ago also have you seen the video
that games manager work 100 100 put on
his instagram he puts a video where um
kim um
what's her name what's kim's sister's
name the the oldest one
no no
courtney was courtney asked him like um
about the sexy but kim was like yeah i
planned it it's on i plan to release it
apart from that vlad
interviewed the guy that that actually
that was the channel that had it the
youtube channel guy the guy that
released it the guy that actually bought
the tape from kim
i don't know i don't know the guy's name
but it's been out i've been known about
this time ago that they planned it
create all of them they planned all of
that to come out it goes back to like
crazy like it's like women taking
advantage of that like protector
instinct yeah like she's even taking
advantage of kanye yeah this is
happening to a billionaire who else is
it happening yeah
sorry when it lashes out online everyone
goes oh it's crazy this is that and i
feel like obviously we know what kanye's
on kanye's walked into this blindly
thinking oh my gosh there's another tape
out there they're gonna take
advantage of the mother of my children
these guys don't know that this thing's
been employed to me i didn't know the
extent i always had it in my back of my
mind that you know what's her name um
chris what did you call her chris john
young was like christian
and you're liking that the north korean
leader i always knew in my head that she
must have something to do with this this
woman is always about making money but
she literally
pimped out her daughter and how messed
up that is disgusting and on the top of
that lie to us to make it look like oh
the tape was leaked
and you know to be honest i thought it
was leaked though i never thought yeah i
never had or anything to be honest i
never thought it was planned so carly
what me are you talking about earlier um
it's a question to you guys
if he was in their position would you
take it back what the tape no i wouldn't
take it back take the tape back i gotta
understand it's already out take it back
and then would you
given a scenario if he was in their
position
right now
if they said look you could take it all
back okay would you take it back but
lose your billions no no i'm keeping
them billions i'm not going to lie back
i don't know because it's not about
the money i just no i just think when it
when when you have kids it's not about
you
and like as a mom like i genuine
like
i genuinely think like
you should want the kids to be happy
above you and above all else
so
like if you have a chance to save your
kids from that
like i agree that's a very good point
she would have been fine like she
wouldn't have been as famous or as rich
but she's yeah they weren't broke
yeah
they weren't broke i know they were
never broken
i mean we can only talk about
what happened after that take
when the way it went
so what they've gone the levels are
completely i mean i mean each of almost
each of them are billionaires bro it's
not just one d that gets to a point
where you're rich where being any richer
doesn't change your life yeah did you
get it so you take it back then no i'm
not saying i would take it back the
point i'm trying that was that was the
question
i get that but the point i'm trying to
make is you're saying oh well they
wouldn't be rich they were calm
i get but you've already made decisions
i don't know what side are you playing
telling your soul but also
i don't think
to be honest kudos to kim right i feel
like
she's she's a
beast when it comes to business i
personally think that obviously i feel
like the uh sexy probably did more harm
than good i feel like even without this
sex tape she would have still become
what she became because she was
came before she was um she was a stylist
for paris hilton ah that one's getting
another oh she was what is what is paris
what did paris do you know paris but no
but what are the paris but listen let me
tell you paris who had a sex tape but
guess what paris paris um dad
has a dynasty paris hilton's that's
correct so she's had money no but then
but that's the same thing they want
broke either buffalo
but already famous now i get that the
point i'm making to you that is this
right when you when you see like okay
cool you know that's there's a
difference between watching someone do
something and not capitalize off of it
right yeah and then you actually like
what you're saying i agree with you
right you having that
that i'm not taking away from her
brilliance when it comes to business and
stuff right but you could have okay i've
got all these ideas right to go to be at
this spot
i need something
and i can't
and then you see someone like paris
do something and you saw
what the kind of attention it it gained
but she didn't do nothing with it
because it was bear in mind this is the
same circle we're talking about right
and it's like you i could do that better
let me say so and i can bear it in mind
again you mentioned a point where that
tape when it came out the way they had
planned it
it was for her
to look like a victim and we're talking
about this is an error of where it
propelled
people like rihanna and demla when being
that victim kind of like propels their
career to the next level let me say
something
um
kim
uh paris hilton
they haven't been they're not the first
people or or celebrities to have a sex
tape brutal that's pam
yeah there are other people that have
had sex tapes sex scandals even by one
plant well even jeff kennedy's brother
um
had one with marilyn monroe yeah yeah
but that was way back have you seen that
one no
okay
we've all heard about it and we've all
heard about it but we haven't seen it
but listen
there are a lot of people that even
currently there are a lot of people that
have had sex tapes that he didn't do
anything for them okay
kim
assad's the sex tape right
she's she was known as a socialite you
know she always used to be absolutely
hard worker all the parties and
everything so
when people talk about when people focus
on the sex safe sex tape it's like
she's just had one sex tape people act
like she's had multiple wait but
remember who ray j was at that time i
think we're forgetting that yeah no but
remember who ray j was at that time
known as brandy's brother it wasn't
really
she's a beast we have to give it to the
girl now she i agree with you like like
i think she would have been successful
regardless i don't think she would have
been as successful though
like she wouldn't she probably would be
like
i bet she would have done good which
there's nowhere she'd be a billionaire
billionaire say something she's always
capitalized on her looks i agree with
looks is currency i feel like basically
she's always capitalized on her looks
the sex
only became she changed let me tell you
because now she's had children right i
look at her so differently when i saw
that clip where she was crying like oh
my gosh kanye saint just found the
advert on roblox yeah
these times you planned this
you like do you know how i feel she's a
psych ward like amber ward because yes
you may be a great businesswoman but
you're actually here doing fake tears
for something that you've planned how do
i now not know you planned that roblox
advert to now to make you look like the
victim well then life is planned
they plan everything right that's why
i'm saying this
and yeah that's what
it's got to change your brain a little
bit like to be on reality tv most of
your life right
you gotta so they go they live for being
a victim you're rewarded rewarded for
being dramatic your reward like
how do you know and that's the reason
why i'm making the point i mean
you're all your whole entire life is an
act where you've been acting so long
that it's now become your reality do you
guys understand so this is what i'm
saying i don't think with that tape it's
like a football match you know when
you're losing and you get that goal one
goal back and it changes the momentum of
everything is literally like that that
tape
changed there was a momentum for her but
obviously don't get me wrong the hard
work and all of that like what the right
example you made where
people do get this opportunity but
without the worker and all of that stuff
is nothing right but she had that
obviously so so credit to her in that
aspect but that still doesn't take away
from the fact that without that and all
of that i don't think she will be a
billionaire where she is right now i
don't i don't believe that i think with
what with their family they're doing
they'll do whatever it takes to really
get money yeah you know they want money
yeah so yeah i mean she did that she and
her kids like later on are going to look
at that
and
imagine other kids talking about your
mom's sex tape and that's what we were
talking about episode
yeah and it's just disgusting because
you're crying acting like we don't know
you planned it it's not stuff that's
literally called blood money mom do you
know what i mean but no one can explain
like what she actually does like how
well besides the sex like how she got
famous or why is she famous that's a
good point go with kanye kanye was a big
party
right yeah she's had some high profile
weddings
yeah yeah so that's all part of it she's
built it up dating up yeah do you know
what i'm saying yeah kanye
yeah it just hides the stuff yeah it's
okay what
what
what does it taste like it's like
underwear
stuff there's a hat stuff bro it's just
underwear oh it's just
it's it's shape-wise yeah
[Laughter]
so are there any more super chat since
the last i think that was all of them
or did i miss one
um i'll check for you okay well while he
does that why don't we go around say any
closing thoughts that you guys had guys
have and just like where they can find
you okay
stop from that outside
uh i believe that we need to start the
mento movement
and i believe
i would love it if you did that yeah
no not that one please no i don't want a
problem no i hate the [ __ ] if she
wears it she's gonna wear it i'm not
yeah the [ __ ]
just hate to hit the [ __ ] it could be
men are [ __ ] too yeah okay hit the
[ __ ] hit the wrongdoers
yeah let's add them in i'm not
advocating for violence guys no anyway
mr test that's where you find me mr tetz
underscore yp that's my instagram and uh
i'll close off by saying
men to movement let's move
i think after a second what you said man
definitely mentioned that we need to
protect men are all customers you know i
mean especially you men go through
i'm alright well protected
especially what what men do you have to
go through here definitely that that is
key and yeah um
zoma
one underscore zoma
and in my opinion podcast uk
over to you sir right um
i think men should be
you know given a fair chance
i think men should be listened to
um
i think women should be taught from
young to keep their hands to themselves
so as so so as men to mentor should be
thought the same thing
um you can't i don't have any instagram
i have a brand account where i messaged
her from
but
share your burner account nope
but let's flood it i have well i'm on
snapchat um chookysnap so that's
c-h-u-k-i-e
snap and uh you can check me on uh you
can check me on youtube
at um stephen chuck d
so stephen with the ph
chuck d where i might give
you know relationship advice whoa
yeah
so yeah
yeah that's it you gotta catch me on
youtube on snapchat
uh old girl needs to go to a psych ward
[Laughter]
um you can follow me on ig
speedy.s22
that's all i gotta say
[Music]
uh i want to shout pearl for inviting us
on really appreciate it all you lot
sending super chats i can confirm the
equipment is a1 so certainly that's in
um all i want to say is mandem
pattern up don't hit the women women pan
up don't hit the man then um melinda
sorry unless you're provoked
i am a third of in my opinion podcast so
you can get us on instagram in my
opinion podcast uk and youtube and my
name is melinda underscore iv
yeah
um
yeah everyone keep your hands to
yourself
yeah
i like that
we learned nothing literally
no but real talk like
listen
everyone keep your answer yourself
um let's just be peaceful man let's all
get along dt
aka designate driver official dtm1
instagram and on on on snapchat
i'm also a one photo that in my opinion
podcast uk i know you guys are tired of
that but yeah follow us on instagram
check us out yeah you guys should
definitely check out their podcast it's
very
very interesting thank you thank you
um okay guys um i know i see a lot of um
things in the chat that were about kevin
samuels i don't i don't know what's real
what's not what's going on tell me yeah
i'll tell you this okay okay okay um but
guys thank you so much for watching this
watching the stream don't forget oh i
should look at this camera right this
one
okay i'll look at this one sorry
thank you guys so much for watching the
stream um it's thanks to people like you
guys that um have really taken the show
off in the last like two three months
really appreciate it don't forget to
subscribe to the channel like the video
on your way way out and i will talk to
you next